risen jack lemmon aujourd'hui on va
parler déjà bras élite 75 test un
produit qui est sorti et pas longtemps
un produit que je suis content de
pouvoir tester vous faire découvrir si
ce n'était pas déjà le cas parce que
c'est un produit qui est intéressant
saint paul qui est vraiment très
intéressant
il ya plein de choses à dire sur ces
déjà bras élite 75 t en parlant déjà de
la qualité forcément au parlant de tout
ce qui va y avoir autour ce que j'avais
fait le point là-dessus gérera le point
de tous ces magnifiques en parlant de l'
application sur smartphone en parlant de
la réduction de bruit passive
ici pas de réduction proactive en
parlant de la forme en parlant du
maintien parle du confort et surtout
c'est que plus intéressant en parlant de
la qualité audio
il ya plein de choses à dire sous divers
[Musique]
non
quand on parle d'écouteurs forcément la
première chose à dire c'est la qualité
c'est la qualité audio parce que c'est
une expérience que vous allez retenir
c'est vraiment le son ou des lavoirs
dans nos oreilles mais il n'ya pas que
ça il ya plein de choses autour
aujourd'hui il ya plein de choses qui
vont être importantes y avoir un petit
mot l'autonomie va y avoir le boîtier va
y avoir la compacité va y avoir la tenue
dans l'oreille va ya voir l'application
quelques pas dans un smartphone dans une
poche que monsieur bré oublié de sortir
l'application
il ya plein de choses à dire mais la
base le fondamental au niveau des
écouteurs ça reste quand même la qualité
audio la qualité sonore et c'est un truc
qui est vraiment intéressant avec cette
jabra élite 75 prix parce que ya un
boulot cet effet est une évolution été
fait c'est vraiment intéressant parce
qu'il propose mais on n'est pas loin
on n'est pas loin on n'est pas loin de
jabra manque encore un truc et je vais
vous expliquer pourquoi je vais vous
expliquer quel est le truc qui manque au
niveau de cette jabra elik 75 tc a pas
grand chose mais c'est dommage c'est
dommage parce que ça c'est vachement
sympa parce que déjà bras fait vraiment
un super boulot sans ces écouteurs il
faut un super boulot au niveau du
produit en lui-même le packaging est
bien l expérience est intéressante à
plein de choses à moitié quand tu mets
ta la promesse fondamental c'est la
qualité audio et à il manque un petit
quelque chose
france médard hier en gare de sa
ensemble on va commencer par la partie
packaging j'aime bien j'aime bien ce
jaune de jabrane j'aime bien le
packaging j'aime bien ce qu'ils font
faut toujours des produits qui sont très
sympas qui tiennent leurs promesses à un
point de vue commun statique et
l'expérience
l'échouage lorsque vous venez d'ouvrir
aider vous avez hop le petit capuchon
vous serez ensuite vous ouvrez le tiroir
ici est normalement vos petits écouteurs
sont là pour moi je les ai roger là
dedans c'est plutôt normal ça vous
explique un petit peu coiffeur ça vous
prend vraiment par là mais ça s'est
vraiment bien ça vous dit télécharger
votre application pour venir
personnaliser l'expérience vous avez
toutes les infos derrière qui vous
explique vraiment comment faire pour les
éteindre
ils vont dans la boîte pour les sortir
vous les allumer discute avec votre
smartphone vous avez l'application face
est vraiment bien
ils vous marquent dès le départ dès le
départ de venir télécharger votre
application vous avez votre botte qui
est là vos écouteurs
à l'intérieur vous retrouvez votre câble
et votre différentes tailles au niveau
de vos en bout pour votre vos écouteurs
donc c'est bien ça marche c'est très
clair très bien expliqué donc de ce
point de vue là c'est vraiment apprécié
que vous avez vos petites boîtes qui est
la jabra vol trouve mignonne bien fait
format compact très très bien dans la
ch les écouteurs en eux mêmes sont
vraiment cool ils ont une vraie vraie
vraie vraie vraie vraie bonne tenue dans
l'oreille ça c'est vraiment super point
positif il ya quatre microphones qui
vont être là pour passer des coups de
fil qui vont vous aider à lutter contre
les bruits environnants qui vont vous
aider également pour pouvoir entendre ce
qui se passe à l'extérieur parce que
vous avez une très bonne réduction de
bruit passive là dessus ici pas de
réduction de bruit active mais ça marche
vraiment bien vous avez de la recharge
ici en usb c'est vous avez l'autonomie
qui est quand même vraiment bonne vous
avez septembre à peu près d'autonomie de
lons 7h30 moi j'ai pas trouvé exactement
7 heures 30 de ce côté je suis pas non
plus avec le chronomètre mais cette
heure vous les avez sans aucun problème
28 heures avec l'étui vous avez de la
recharge rapide en 15 minutes de charge
vous écoutez une heure musique et une
charge complète à peu près deux heures
et demie voilà peu pour la question de
l'autonomie du boîtier pour se mettre un
peu proche vous et moi pour regarder
sont des intra auriculaires des intra
auriculaires son dos des petits
écouteurs qui viennent directement de
votre riad et vous tournez vous mettez
sommes même pas un petit quart de tour
la tenue elle est parfaite dans
l'oreille ils tiennent parfaitement dans
l'oreille c'est très facile à installer
très très facile à mettre en place
je prends je tourne sam l'install sam la
vis et là hop qui entend connecte ils
sont connectés directement sais pas si
vous vous rendez compte mais il ya
vraiment une excellente tenue satire
coop vient par larissa tient
parfaitement bien alors vous arrêtez pas
pourra le faire du propos mais pour
aller courir en extérieur ça marche
vraiment bien eu des petits pavés pour
venir a pu en fait sont pas des plus
actifs sont des boutons vous appuyer une
fois ici vous mettez la musique vous
répugnez une fois vous arrêter la
musique la même chose si votre téléphone
sonne une fois que décrocher des pilotes
fois vous raccrochez un grand classique
c'est simple quelqu'un vous appelle
voulait pas répondre vous appuyé deux
fois ça va rejeter l'appel
et si vous utilisez votre assistant
vocal que ce soit la scène locale de
votre téléphone c'est à dire syrie où l
assistant ou alors amazon alexa pour
venir paramétrable et bien vous appuyé
deux fois dessus quel temps fait-il en
ce moment il fait 14 degrés avec du
soleil ok super ça me va bien selon les
prévenus rockets et lorsque j'ai mes
deux écouteurs je maintiens acculé ici
ça va augmenter le volume du côté gauche
j'appuie une fois ça va me désactiver ou
d'activer la fonction on retrouve la
fonction anti flou je sais pas si j'ai
le bon ex en fait ce qui va vous
permettre de faire c'est d'activer les
micros pour entendre ce qui se passe
autour de vous par exemple vous êtes je
sais pas bruyant dans la rue vous
marchez vous voulez entendre il ya des
voitures autour de vous parce qu'il ya
ceux qui ferment très très
impressionnant c'est la réduction
passive ça devient très très bien mais
extrêmement bien bouché les oreilles
il faut vous avez bien choisi la taille
de vos en bout ici eh bien ça doit se
positionner extrêmement facilement dans
vos oreilles il ya un vrai confort ça
c'est cool et ça devient très très très
très très bien bouché les oreilles
du coup lorsque vous êtes comme ça vous
êtes extrêmement bien bouché vraiment ça
vous coupe de l'extérieur et vous dès
cette fonction sur flu qui vous permet
effectivement d'entendre ce qui se passe
là j'ai activé je rappe lui une fois ça
va de la désactiver et j'ai vraiment la
réduction passive ça nous coûte vraiment
l'extérieur c'est vraiment très très
efficace il ya super boulot qu'ils
étaient par déjà voir à l'habitude donc
ça s'est vraiment bien alors par contre
ça vous ouvre mais ça vous activerez
micro d'aucun côté un petit peu
métallique ce n'est pas extrêmement
naturelle mais malgré tout je veux
savoir quand même plutôt bien
lorsque je suis en train de passer un
coup de fil une fois ça permet de couper
le micro de transformer de réactiver le
micro si je veux pas que les personnes
avec qui je téléphone entendre ce que
j'ai à dire à ce moment là lorsque je
laisse appuyé ici gaza baisse le volume
donc je laisse appuyer sa nuque le
volume cela s'appuyer ça te laisse le
volume j'ai appuyé deux fois up morceau
suivant
et lorsque je passe un coup de fil et
chapuis deux fois ça me fait l'effet
locales les faits le cas ça permet
d'entendre ma voix lorsque je passe un
coup de fil
tout simplement grâce au micro qui vont
entendre ma voix qui vont bien j'étais
dedans spam et de m'entendre
cette ville d'avoir un petit côté sourds
ne pas entendre ce qu'on dit c'est un
peu plus conférence nouveau passer un
coup de fil
et lorsque j'écoute de la musique je
puis trois fois ça me permet de relire
le morceau de jeunes d'écouté je rate à
nouveau trois fois ça permet d'aller au
morceau précédent
voilà un petit peu comment ça marche au
niveau des commandes allant bon il
commence comme tout vous commencez par
les apprendre à vous les avez appris que
vous avez compris c'est facile ça
devient intuitif
au début on comprend pas trop comme
rouler sur des boutons et parce qu'on a
un pavé tactile au début a tendance à
toucher légèrement ça marche pas il faut
appuyer californie renforcer bhutto il
faut prôner choper le coup ça marche au
début c'est pas hyper intuitive et
simple comme tout faut prendre
l'habitude il faut que vous l'avez ça
marche très bien pour venir éteindre
c'est très facile vous les prenez et
vous voulez et les ranger up fall est du
bon côté
vous venez le ranger dans sa boite ça
vient c'est aimante et c'est facile ça
se met en place
hop là ils sont éteints pour les allumer
exactement la même chose vous prenez
vous lever hop là vous les sortez et là
ils sont allumés il faut savoir tout ce
que vous avez vos deux écouteurs dans
les oreilles et lorsque vous en lv1 et
bien ça va venir couper la musique up
dac vous le prenez vous l'enlever mais
par contre vous pouvez la réactiver vous
appuyez vous l'écoutez uniquement sur la
droite vous pouvez pas le faire
uniquement avec la gauche
la m c'est la droite la gauche ne les
parcs en tout cas pour l'instant tout ça
tourne vers évidemment sur ios et se
rendre au heat vous avez l'application
ici la cendre plus
vous venez vous ouvrez ça marche alors
lorsque vous avez connecter vos
écouteurs ne vous allez voir c'est assez
simple vous avez plusieurs possibilités
ça je vous avait déjà montré dans un des
précédents tests de produits de jabra
c'est vraiment intéressant que ça c'est
je dirais le truc de base lorsque vous
êtes dans les transports en commun vous
avez des réglages différents et aux
mêmes des réglages lorsque vous êtes aux
jo sur la partie focus parti ce que vous
voulez partir au travail quand vous le
souhaitez
tu veux montrer que sur celle là vous
allez voir ça c'est simple la partie au
flou qui vous permettra effectivement et
bien d'entendre à travers devons pouvoir
régler ici le volume des micros en fait
pour injecter plus ou moins de son dans
vos oreilles
ici la partie équaliseur ça c'est pour
moi c'est un truc est très très très
très important sur une application par
défaut vous êtes flap moi lise un petit
historique se veut le montrer si c'est
un petit peu cassée au niveau des
médiums comme peut vraiment leur calibre
et comme vous voulez et après vous avez
plusieurs possibilités
vous pouvez mettre en mode parole ça va
vous casser un peu les graves et les
aigus pendant vraiment que la partie
médium qui correspondrait aux fréquences
de la boit plus de basses ça va être
déjà très très flatteur et déjà calée
pas mal de graves comme ça donc vous
allez bien monter un peu plus bon ça
marche plus début si vous le souhaitez
pour avoir plus de cymbales et plus de
sons clairs fluide bon ya pas mal de
possibilités dynamiser moi ce que je
vous conseille de vous remettre par les
faux et ensuite de venir régler par
rapport à ce que vous aimez entendre
attention quand même parce que vous avez
quand même pas mal de grave ici vous
avez cinq bandes de fréquences
il aurait pu y en avoir plus mais ça
vous permet quand même déjà de faire les
réglages de base et devenir paramétrer
la musique par rapport à ce que vous
aimez écouter ensuite vous avez un truc
assez intéressant ça fait sens de skype
lance en skate c'est assez marrant ça
vous permet d'avoir différents types de
sons dans vos oreilles
si vous voulez pas écouter la musique ne
vous voulez masquer un petit peu le
bruit autour de vous mettre dans une
ambiance là je dirais bruit roesbrugghe
blanc oui le ventilateur cascades plongé
cette femme elle a besoin d'être un peu
sous l'eau avec le côté de plongée il a
coûté 1 pour relaxe en cascade aussi
vagues de l'océan jours de pluie chants
d'oiseaux orage parfait chlapak
morisseau le capot noir ou soma ça donne
envie d'aller au taux est donc j'ai eu
la visite des parents comme ce que
j'aime bien c'est les chants d'oiseaux
faut simplement hypra une prime très
relaxant et après vous allez ce qu'ils
appellent les ambiances confortable
cavernes foule c'est pas mal franchement
c'est pas mal lorsque vous voulez un
petit peu coupé que voulez pas écouter
de la musique mais vous voulez un petit
sont derrière pour avoir un côté un
petit peu relaxant alors c'est fait
c'est bien évidemment complètement faux
mais c'est un effet qui a servi l'accent
sur le cerveau voyez si j'ai le niveau
de batterie de mes deux écouteurs ici
j'ai niveau de batterie de mon boitier
je peux mettre à jour mon fils m'a en
fait c'est pas mal de possibilités c'est
bien c'est simple intuitif le rapid en
france elle a rempli marche très très
bien
on a les écouteurs qui sont ip55 salies
résistant à l'eau et à la poussière
alors vous n'allez pas vous baigner avec
un pc pas fait pour ça vous n'allez pas
les jeter dans l'eau mais si vous avez
un petit peu d'eau lorsqu'il pleut vous
êtes quand même relativement tranquille
donc ça c'est bien je trouve que donc on
a des produits qui sont de bonne qualité
qui sonne bien on est une application
qui est cool avec un équaliseur tous qui
est très complet un produit qui bien
qu'elle est jolie mais qu'en est-il
réellement de l'expérience audio alors
c'est un petit peu là où le bât blesse
parce que je trouve que les produits
sont bien il ya très bon boulot a été
fait par le jabra gay belle montée en
gamme de djaballah dessus néanmoins
c'est pas encore parfait il va manquer
certaines choses il va manquer vraiment
une meilleure définition de une
meilleure qualité audio peut-être de la
pts à péter xhd probablement duel des as
et on se retrouve avec des codecs de
base ça fonctionne ça fait le taf mais
je dirais que quand j'ai vu le prix 179
euros je me suis dit ah c'est
intéressant
179 euros c'est aussi le prix d'un autre
produit c'est ça l'airpod à leurs potes
de base sans la recharge la réduction
c'est du coup le même tarif donc du coup
on vit on est quasiment passe alors on
est en face oui et non oui bon c'est pas
tout à fait la même chose
la différence vous allez avoir avec elle
et djabraïl 75 t c'est qu'effectivement
vous avez réduction de bruit passif
qu'il est vraiment bush et votre conduit
auditif pour vous couper un peu du monde
extérieur et le fail extrêmement bien
par contre effectivement sur les repos
tu es bien vous n'avez pas de réduction
de bruit passive vous prenez vos
écouteurs vous les posez là si vous avez
du son extérieur ça passe ça vient
légèrement bloqué mais pas grand chose
donc on n'est pas tout à fait sans la
même chose mais on est sur le même tarif
et moi je suis consommateur comme tous
les consommateurs je regarde
effectivement le produit j'aurais
effectivement si le tarif et je le dis
du coup quelle différence je vais avoir
entre les djabraïl 75 t et l'airpod je
pourrais pas dire polypro ils sont pâles
tous dans la même barque son trike
lui-même produit récent des produits
coûtent beaucoup plus cher avec la
réduction bruit actif c'est autre chose
mais par contre ici je pose juste la
question de la qualité audio de la
qualité sonore est bien c'est un petit
peu ce qui me gêne parce que je trouve
que effectivement sur cette jabra it 75
t la qualité les parades
on va pas se mentir avec pas mal c'est
très flatteur dans le grade ça ronronne
de base si vous voulez mon temps parce
que l'isr au niveau des grappes là c'est
que vous allez vraiment que ce rebond
est pour moi toujours tendance à me dire
que lorsqu'on vient en rajouter au
niveau des grave c'est qu'on veut cacher
quelque chose alors si je suis pas sûr
qu'ils veulent cacher quelque chose mais
je pense qu'ils veulent rajouter un pas
en expérience rajoute un petit peu en
groovy au niveau des médiums leçon il
est pas extraordinaire je trouve un peu
métallique équipe a extrêmement bien
définissez ce que je veux dire vraiment
reprocher à ce produit qui est quand
même à 179 euros 90 franchement les
grèves sont pas mal
il y en a beaucoup vous pouvez venir les
laisser oubliera jouteurs fonction de ce
que vous voulez ça marche pas trop mal
les élus sont aussi assez bien défini
mais je trouve qu'on il nous manque un
peu de précision en un quota potro m'est
avis c'est vraiment ce qui est dommage
pour ce produit
a contrario si vous venez écouter ça
l'airpod d'apple eh bien vous avez un
son qui est beaucoup plus défini un son
qui est de meilleure qualité et qui est
beaucoup plus naturelle et toute la
différence se fait là dessus et c'est
pas un point de détail parce que c'est
un point très important quand on parle
de casque quand on parle d'écouteurs on
en reparle d'intra auriculaires on parle
d' avant tout de qualité audio de
qualité sonore tout le reste autour
c'est bien mais ça c'est la base et la
base pour moi il manque un tout petit
peu à jabba pour y arriver
j'ai des morceaux de référence que
j'écoute à chaque fois lorsque je
déteste je les connais parfaitement bien
je connais très bien les moments où ça
nous y aller des guitares convenir un
petit peu gratter le fond on va vraiment
avoir des points de détails qu'on peut
entendre et mans avec un produit qui est
vraiment très fidèle et de très bonne
qualité mais également de la cymbale de
l'arast qui vous emmener un son très
clair très définis je retrouve très très
très bien avec l'airpod je retrouve
beaucoup moins bien défini avec les jo
bras élite 60 persister et c'est
vraiment ce qui m'embête parce que ces
produits je trouve bien il ya un vrai
travail qui a été fait de la part de
jabra là dessus il ya une vraie
amélioration par rapport aux 65 pts et
la génération précédente
au niveau de la tenue au niveau de la
compacité au niveau de la qualité audio
mais il leur manque encore un petit
quelque chose je pense que ce qui leur
manque ce sont des meilleurs codex
d'augmenter vraiment sa qualité audio
peut-être 449 euros sur un trouvais ça
un petit peu mieux mais comme on trouve
face à des produits comme les repose au
même tarif
et bien c'est là où ça coince à puce
c'est pas le même produit on les sent
des intra on n'est pas sur les autres à
une en terme d'expérience et de qualité
du pur c'est vraiment s'y connaissent et
ça m'embête ça m'embête très loin parce
que je trouve intéressant alors si vous
cherchez néanmoins des intra si vous
voulez une réduction de passif si vous
voyez une excellente réduction de bruit
passive et que c'est déjà bras ils se
sentent testez vous font de l'oeil et
bien allez-y sans aucun problème parce
que ils sont quand même bien la qualité
audio qui correct mais il leur manque un
petit quelque chose pour encore un dia
points gap de précision fangak de
définition et une fois que ce sera fait
pour moi on arriva sur l'épreuve des
trucs vraiment vraiment vraiment à qui
font beaucoup de mal à la concurrence
pour l'instant c'est bien mais peut
faire mieux que moi ce que vous en
pensez comment vont les trouver ces
djabraïl et 75 c est ce que vous
pourriez être intéressé si l'intérieur
nous a mis un lien en bas dans la
description je trouve quand même
récente on ne crache pas dans la soupe
aux choux que les produits sont bien
bien réussi mais à ça fait râler suppose
que vous en pensez en bas on se retrouve
dès demain on continue à parler de
textes grâce à demain